welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and if you're one
of the fans that doesn't mind turning to
the dark side and having the upcoming
Star Wars movie the rise of Skywalker
runed then this is the video for you in
the wake of the recently leaked images
that show the film's ending we have a
whole host of new information on the
storyline and throughout this video
we're going to be going over all of
these leaks as well as our thoughts on
what it means for the movie there will
of course be heavy spoilers here and
whilst all leaks like this should be
taken with a grain of salt Disney have
been blocking videos on YouTube that
show the images so this pretty much
confirms them as being true a convert
the images in this video because of the
aforementioned reason but we've got
enough here that it should give you an
idea of what happens in them as well as
what it means for the movie without the
way I just want to give a huge thank you
for click in this video now let's get
into our Star Wars the rise of Skywalker
breakdown okay so I'm just gonna be
going through the original leaks and
talking about how the reshoots have
changed the plot and what it means for
the rest of the movie I already have an
extensive breakdown of the leaked plot
that we got earlier in the air but if
you haven't had a chance to watch that
then don't worry because we'll be
covering the majority of it here as well
as how the plot points have changed
these leaks come from reddit user Jedi
paksas who pretty much detailed
everything that was shown in the earlier
trailers before they even got released
such as the red-eyed c-3po the Knights
of Ren and so on so I think it's safe to
say that the user has at least some
inside information now the user said
that the training scene that was
originally meant to open the movie which
apparently showed a younger Luke
Skywalker training his sister Leia has
been cut instead the beginning of the
movie is now going to take place on a
planet called ex of Gaul and here we
witness a fleet of stardestroyers rising
from the ground this was shown in the
final trailer so we know at the very
least that this scene has been part of
the production process at some point the
user also says that there was an Oracle
scene with kylo Ren that has been
removed and instead of this he will just
come across an item in a chest known as
the Wi-Fi
according to the original leaks the
wayfinder is the MacGuffin of the movie
that can apparently show wherever
Palpatine is and this helps kylo to find
the villain lair in the movie kylo
experiences a force flash where he hears
both Luke and Hans voices before
Palpatine's voice overpowers them and
calls out to him now the scene that
preceded this which involved kylo
savagely killing natives on a planet
before getting to the wayfinder has
apparently been toned down massively
with producers trying to lighten the
character up a bit who wants to come at
the end of the film which is basically
his Redemption as for the scene with Rey
training on the forest planet this was
put in place last minute and wasn't in
the original leaks she similar to Luke
is frustrated with the process of
training and at one point chops down a
tree that falls on bb-8 she tries to
communicate with Luke as well but this
fails and she also tries to give Leia
Luke sole lightsaber kylo manages to
find the Emperor Palpatine and confronts
him and he's angered by the fact that he
has operated in the shadows even going
so far to threaten him
Palpatine doesn't refute that he died on
the Death Star but he also mocks kylo
Ren for saying let the past die this is
kind of JJ's shutting down Rian Johnson
I feel and Palpatine details that the
past is the key to the future talks
about race lineage and the construction
of the Sith fleet at the start he also
states that the Empire needs a ruler and
that he's back to do it we don't really
get much detail about how he returned
but he is very weak physically and this
ties into the process of regaining his
power which I'll get into later in the
leak we then go to the resistance who
are being fed information from general
Hux on the first orders plan through a
spy named boo leo this was originally in
the leaks and it looks like Hawkes has
got sick of the fact he's constantly
pushed to the side by his new commander
played by Richard II Grant Julio talks
about snoke's rise to power and he
confirms that he wasn't a pawn of the
Emperor
he also divulges information on the
fleet and Finn worries that the Empire
will once again begin kidnapping
children in order to man it cut to kylo
Ren who is aware that there's a mole in
the first order and he discovers boo leo
who he tortures instead of killing him
though he realizes he can use him as a
way to draw right out and begins to put
a plan in action
the resistance learn about the way finer
through Luke's notes in the Jedi texts
and they go to Busan I did seek out a
hermit that Luke knew whilst there right
in Kyllo connect through the force and
kylo mocks her about her parents saying
that he's the only one who will accept
her ray tries to warn them that they are
coming for them but it's too late and
they get ambushed by storm troopers but
luckily Lando shows up and helps them
Lando says that he and Luke were looking
for Sith artifacts named Archie and that
they have knowledge on how to use the
weight finder Lando also confirms Finn's
theory that the first order are
kidnapping children to turn them into
stormtroopers after all this the first
order appears again and Lando say see
iconic line I've got a bad feeling about
this he and the rest of the resistance
fighters flee on speeders as they're
pursued by the first order and the
Knights of Ren most of them get away
except for those in the Millennium
Falcon which includes Chewbacca the ones
that do make it away discover that
Archie was a Sith assassin and that he
wielded a sith dagger that has writing
on it now we know this dagger is in the
movie because we see Rey holding it at
one point in the final trailer so we can
guess that this is correct in the leaked
race ASAP it's tradition for the Sith to
write secrets on their weapons and c-3po
can apparently read this he is unable to
translate it because his programming
forbids it but he overrides this in
order to do it this is why he has red
eyes in the second trailer and why he
also talks about not getting to look at
his friends again in the more recent one
the leak then says that we get details
of Poe dameron's past and which he was a
spice runner with Kari Russell's
character Zuri bliss she is now working
with the resistance and hands over a
first-order security medallion that
allows them to gain access to ships in
their fleet Rey senses Chewie is still
alive and has been transported to kylo
Ren's Star Destroyer so the group hatch
a plan to go and get him while on the
Star Destroyer ray finds Archie's dagger
this scene is similar to when she picked
up Luke's lightsaber in the force
awakens and she gets it after she has a
vision the vision shows Archie
assassinating her parents as they
attempt to hide her and this confirms
that the Sith knew about Rey kylo Ren
then shows up in details that Archie was
meant to take Rey away but her parents
stop this and he talks about the truth
of her
the group managed to escape the ship but
they learned the location of the
resistance and show up and kill lots of
them including Leia following her death
Palpatine grows more confident and
decides that now is the time to make his
move they uncover how to get 2x a goal
and Rey heads there whilst the
resistance fleet and Millennium Falcon
head off in different directions they
want to take the first-order head-on and
by right time so that she can kill
Palpatine upon arriving at EXA goal and
encountering Palpatine Rey is about to
strike him down according to the leaks
Palpatine's actual plan was to have Rey
kill him and take his place as the
leader of the Empire but in the very
last second she senses ren has been
betrayed by the knights of ren because
they secretly work for Palpatine and he
has no more use for him she initiates a
force bond and passes a lightsaber to
him which allows him to fight and defeat
them now originally the leaks said that
Palpatine became Matt Smith after
possessing his body however according to
the new ones the reshoots have changed
this so that the character that matt
smith plays is only used to rejuvenate
Palpatine and now he is once a game
played by Ian McDiarmid
Rey slowly begins to get drained of her
force powers to rejuvenate Palpatine who
then slowly begins to launch this
siffleet the resistance arrived just in
time to take them head-on and whilst Rey
is being drained she reaches out to
other Jedi that have become one with the
force this includes Obi Wan Leia and
Luke
now the original leak said that they
made an appearance here but according to
the new details only their voices can be
heard together with the help of kylo
who's now embraced Ben solo again and
has a blue lightsaber that is said to be
Anakin's the two are able to defeat
Palpatine and end the Sith in the end
Lando and the reinforcements provided by
Zoe bliss take the Sith flee on and finn
manages to trick the first-order into
turning their cannons on themselves
which destroys the fleet having won the
day the survivors celebrate and this
continues across the galaxy similar to
the end of Return of the Jedi the heroes
return to Tatooine where it all began
and Ray has deconstructed both Luke and
Anakin's lightsaber and retooled them to
make one that contains a yellow blade
Rey buries the leftover pieces at Luke's
and she turns round to see her friends a
stranger asks who she is and why she's
come here and Rhea answers by saying Rey
Skywalker the group aula coffin to the
twin sunsets and we see the force ghosts
of some familiar faces beside them
staring out over a galaxy full of hope
which ends the film and that's all of
the leaks that we have honestly it
sounds like a big improvement over the
initial bunch that we got but I can't
help feeling that there are some certain
plot elements that just don't work and I
still feel like Palpatine probably
should have been left out of this film
this is about new characters and new
trilogy and overall it seems too tied to
the originals to truly stand on its own
two feet
they've also turned down kylo so much
that it feels like a neutering of the
character I mean this is a guy who'd
murdered his own father and now all of a
sudden he can be the good guy yeah it
just just doesn't really work for me but
I do know that this is all about
execution so who knows JJ might be able
to pull it off there are some good
moments in here but I will admit on the
whole it sounds more in line with the
last Jedi rather than the force awakens
which in my opinion is the better of the
two movies I guess we will see come
December but at the moment I'm not
getting my hopes up too high as we
really don't know where this could go
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on these leaks and if they have
you any more or less excited for the
film comment below and let me know and
if you enjoy this video then please like
it and make sure you check out my
breakdown on the best theories as to how
power patine survived in it we go over
the ways that make the most sense so
definitely check it out if this video is
peaked your interest talks about the
original Matt Smith plans as well so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more you want to come
chat to me after the video that make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition yte or head over to my
discord server which you'll be linked in
the description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with all the
latest videos so hopefully I see you
over there very soon we're also giving
away a free copy of the Marvel phase 3
part 1 box on blu-ray which contains
Civil War Doctor Strange homecoming
Ragnarok and more and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is
like the video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the Star Wars
weeks in the comments below who will is
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
November and the cell be shipped out
from then to ever get surprised it's the
best of luck to everyone who takes part
this is the channel for people who were
mad into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you